Je sais que ces règles peuvent sembler contraignantes,
mais rappelez-vous que le but de ce cours est
d'apprendre à écrire de manière claire et
persuasive. Réfléchissez à cela. Réfléchissez
à la vérité de votre argument.
fille incroyable
es-tu en train d'essayer de me parent en
ce moment
qui voudrait de moi
tu ne restes pas en contact avec maman elle
ne me dit vraiment que des choses sur toi
pourquoi
parce que c'est tout ce que je veux savoir
pourquoi as-tu pris tout ce poids quelqu'un
une proche de moi est décédée et ça m'a fait un
effet tu ne l'as pas vue depuis
qu'elle avait huit ans et tu vas
renouer avec elle désolé je n'aime pas
ça ce n'est pas une bonne idée je suis désolé
Je suis désolé une fois de plus, je vais t'enfoncer un
couteau en plein dans la peau Je jure devant Dieu
qu'est-ce que ça va faire mes
organes internes sont à deux pieds au moins des
rires
pourquoi avez-vous soudainement besoin de la voir si
mal pourquoi maintenant
je suis  inquiet qu'elle ait oublié quelle
personne incroyable elle est,
j'ai besoin de savoir  qu'elle va avoir une
vie décente où elle se soucie des gens
et ça ira juste
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de savoir que
je
veux écrire avec ma vie
[Musique]